[Music]
foreign
some stories got lost along the way
maybe if they had taught us everything
to happen
my brother would have left that knife
where he found it
I will play I won't quit
you know what I think we should do right
now go to the party come on let's go
if you play with me then I'll let you go
to your party and I won't call Mom okay
Joe what game do you want to play
[Music]
camera we'll all say I will play I won't
quit
tell me demon
demon am I it
morgas
let's play
Marcus
how are you ready to play hide and seek
Marcus why do you have that knife bye
why are you doing this
three go what is going on it's not him
it's the knife
found you
hey buddy you're just messing with us
right how about something
and it's my big wind
what if we win only one way to find out
I will play
what's happening I will play it I won't
quit
I will play
let's play a new game
[Music]
foreign